before we get into it I want to give a
big THANK YOU to Nord VPN for sponsoring
this video
Nord VPN is an easy to use an incredibly
effective way to protect your privacy
and security online I tried at least
three other VPN providers before Nord
VPN but Nord is by far the easiest and
fastest option I found you just
installed the app on your desktop and
mobile device and with a simple click
your online activity becomes encrypted
which allows you to stop large companies
and governments from monitoring and
manipulating your presence online and
with article 13 and other recent attacks
on net neutrality using Nord VPN is no
longer an option for me it is a
necessity Nord gives you access to
thousands of servers around the world
and connecting to a server in a
different country means you can get
quick and safe access to all the content
available in that country as if you were
there Nord VPN is currently offering an
incredible deal when you go to Nord be P
n comm slash anime uproar 75% off a
three-year plan plus if you use the code
anime uproar right now you will receive
an extra month for free that's Nord VPN
dot-com slash anime uproar or just click
the link in the description but please
act now this is a limited time offer
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
explaining how each member of the ten
commandments including previous member
mellotts relate to their commandment we
will also pay attention to the special
power that comes along with the specific
commandment this video idea was actually
suggested on my every character's sin
explained video and then I got curious
about the commandments and wanted to do
more research on them and next thing you
know here we are so feel free to leave a
suggestion for a future video in the
comments and you might just see it pop
up in your feed in the near future make
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
seven deadly sins videos and if you're
already subscribed make sure to hit that
notification bell so you actually get
notified when new videos come out now
it's out further ado let's jump into the
video let's start with froderick
the commandment of selflessness
selflessness is defined as concerned
more with the needs and wishes of others
than with one's own the commandment
appears to have such an effect that
whoever in his presence harbors feelings
of selfishness and greed will lose their
memories feelings and their whole sense
of self obviously since in many ways the
Ten Commandments were the antagonist of
the story for a long time their specific
Commandments which all seem to suggest
positive virtues will be ironic when it
comes to their character fraud Rijn was
responsible for killing Liz he framed
the son deadly sins for zarathos is dead
and no doubt did other terrible stuff
however he does in the end live up to
his commandment of selflessness before
he didn't understand selflessness
we get a flashback of him talking to go
thir after meliodas left and demon side
during the holy war fraud Rinna Soames
Mellie Otis acted selfishly at first and
fled from the war but go through Towson
Mellie Otis didn't flee he threw himself
into the fight for the sake of the one
he loves
he asks fraud Rijn if he can relate and
he says no I can't he could not relate
to putting someone else's wishes and
desires above his own however
fast-forward 3000 years to the moment
when Mellie Otis is about to kill
froderick Roger and decides to
self-destruct and take everyone with him
to the grave
grim
or rushes in he traps fraud rent and
himself in one of his defensive barriers
and begs him not to kill his dad or
anyone else
Rajan while he was in dreyfuses body has
come to love Gris amore as his own son
although he didn't want to be able to
relate to feelings of love that make you
prioritize others over yourself he
suggests that he can now relate to such
feelings thanks to griot more rather
than going out with a bang and
potentially taking Mellie Otis and his
loved ones with him Rajan prioritizes
Greer Moore's wishes and everyone's
safety and willingly gives himself over
to Mellie Otis to be brutally killed in
the end his final act is an act of
selflessness he shows that he is more
concerned with the needs and wishes of
Greer more than his own before fraud
Rijn the demon goat her the creator of
the doll go third that we know possessed
the commandment of selflessness because
the commandment could curse anyone with
self-interest or ambition and could even
affect demons in the demon world the
demon king who gifted the demon go
through with the commandment imprisoned
him for 500 years at first king in
gloxinia spotty thinks that demon Gotha
is acting selfishly when he takes
advantage of the turmoil during the holy
war to escape from jail however Gotha
also proves to be selfless he explains
that his goal is to be a free man so
that he could end the holy war the demon
go through sacrifice as his own life in
order to end a holy war at least
temporarily one of his final requests is
not for himself but for the doll goat
there he asks Deanne and King to be his
friends and lead him down the right path
he is concerned for the doll Gotha in
his final moments and not for himself he
then proceeds to use a forbidden spell
with go Thurs help that tampers with
everyone's memories of the Archangel
mile including the memories of the gods
the demon king and the supreme deity
since the spell required so much power
the demon goat are needed his dolls help
and even with it still needed to use
every last drop of his life force to
activate it thus he willingly died so
that he could stop the war and all of
the suffering that it caused his final
act as with fraud Rijn was an act of
selflessness we should also look at Argo
third
all because he can also be said to have
possessed the commandment of
selflessness with his creator
in fact fraud Rijn says that it was go
Thurs own commandment that erased his
memories and feelings at times he seems
selfish like when he heard skill and her
brother so that he can better understand
the feeling of love however this is
usually the result of him simply not
knowing what's right and what's wrong
at his core with his memories and
feelings intact
Gotha is a selfless person although he
can't cure her he is willing to give up
his own life if it would save his lover
Nadja furthermore later on in the series
we see that he is willing to risk his
own life for his friends and to help
mail out who is suffering because of the
memory altering spell that Gotha and his
creator used to stop the holy war
luckily he didn't have to sacrifice his
life like the others but he has shown
through his actions that he is often a
selfless person next let's look at the
land the commandment of truth being
truthful means being honest it is the
opposite of lying to someone which is
why the commandment of truth turns
anyone who lies in Galan's presence to
stone and it applies to the user as well
only those who are actually aware that
they are telling a lie are affected by
the commandments curse interestingly
enough after he absorbs the commandment
mile is able to use it to cancel out go
there's allusions galiyan doesn't get as
much character development as froderick
but we do know that he is forced to be
an honest guy because of his commandment
which will turn him to stone if he lies
or goes back on his word in the end
though he can't live up to his
commandment against esken or he says and
I quote gland of truth never goes
against his word let's fight to the
death
however he gets so scared when he
witnesses ESCA NORs immense power that
he begins to run away before either one
of them is dead because he goes back on
his word his commandment activates
turning him to stone so props to Oscar
nor who was Opie enough to turn the land
of truth into a liar hashtag praise the
Sun drawl possessed the commandment of
patience
troll is the founder of the giant clan
and the strongest giant in history joel
towers over other Giants in size he's
the creator of drawls dance and the name
for Baylor's I comes from his human name
bail or
since he has the ability to determine
the strength of his opponents and even
read their minds just by looking at them
his skills and accomplishments are
beyond impressive now let's take a
closer look at his commandment patience
is defined as the capacity to accept or
tolerate delay trouble or suffering
without getting angry or upset his big
challenge came when soldiers
easily defeated him in the past and hurt
his pride as veliotis explained drawl
always aimed to be the strongest and
sell just trampled on that dream and
crushed his pride Zell just gave him two
options to die or join the 10
commandments troll chose to join the 10
commandments on the spot at that time he
did not live up to the commandment of
patience he did not tolerate his defeat
well nor did he delay his decision until
he could figure out the right path
however he learns through Dan's example
that he could have found an alternative
path if he practiced patience he could
have run away but he couldn't tolerate
having his pride crushed and jumped to
the wrong decision on the spot
eventually he learns the error of his
ways and leaves the 10 commandments
along with gloxinia unfortunately the
specific curse associated with the
commandment of patience is still unknown
gloxinia the first very king possessed
the commandment of repose repose is
defined as a state of rest sleep or
tranquility this is the opposite of the
wakelock see and behaved when he thought
that the human ro had killed his sister
gloxinia completely loses himself to his
anger and brutally kills the human even
though he actually saved his sister
unlike king who manages to keep his cool
in the end and as a result stops his
spirit spear in time gloxinia cannot
maintain his tranquillity and thus
mistakenly jumps to the wrong conclusion
he kills ro and doesn't even check to
find out that his sister's actually
alive however gloxinia eventually
realizes that he was wrong he becomes
much more tranquil and clear-headed as
the series goes on and he realizes that
he made a mistake and that he should
have acted like king did he realizes
that ro wasn't really a bad guy and that
he even came back in the form of oslo to
watch over his sister and what's
precious to her so eventually he regains
his tranquility and in doing so man just
up to the commandment of repose as
withdrawals commandment the effects of
luck Sania's commandment are still
unknown gray road was the commandment of
pacifism pacifism is the belief that any
violence including war is unjustifiable
under any circumstances and that all
disputes should be settled by peaceful
means gray roads commandment corresponds
with the DAO shalt not kill commandments
the commandments curse activates if
anyone kills at her presence that person
will have their time stolen from them
and rapidly age until they die gray road
is able to use curse magic on people so
that she can defeat them without
resorting to killing them for instance
she is able to curse Hauser so that all
five of his senses are cut off
additionally if she can turn people into
demons and as fraudulent points out that
leaves most of her opponents with only
two options they can kill the monsters
while they're incubating and die thanks
to gray Rhodes commandment or be killed
by the monsters once they're done
incubating ironically although gray Road
cannot directly kill people she is
responsible for indirectly killing many
unlike some other commandments who get
more character development she does not
turn over a new leaf she does not end up
actually living up to her commandment in
a virtuous way like fraud rend roll and
larceny eventually do mulaskey law was
the commandment of faith faith is
defined as complete trust or confidence
in someone or something ESMA lastly
explains to bond everyone's heart
possesses something they have faith in
and believe in whether it's a God the
sword or a lover it's something very
precious to them but people's hearts are
weak they lose their faith over the
smallest matters it's a vise no matter
how many people Harbor distrust before
me their eyes will burn in bonds case if
he had doubted or hated Elaine even for
a moment his eyes would have burned but
he had complete unshakable faith in her
so he was fine in the official seven
deadly sins character guidebook velasca
Lowe's dream slash hope was the revival
of the demon king although she probably
didn't pick the right person to be
faithful to she did embody her
commandment because of how faithful she
was to the demon king who was pretty
much a god to the demons she was
faithful to him until the
and unlike most of the other ten
commandments who came to doubt the demon
king and chose to prioritize other
things rather than being faithful to him
the last Club takes on all of the seven
deadly sins and says on behalf of the
demon king I will punish you for your
sins she risks her life over and over
again for the demon king and eventually
loses to the sins however it can be said
that she was indeed faithful right up to
the end she proved worthy of the title
mulaskey law of the faith derrière II
the commandment of purity purity is
defined as freedom from immorality
especially of a sexual nature at first
glance it seems deeply ironic that a
villain of the series can be a moral
person after all one of the first things
she does is attack me leotis our
protagonist you also wouldn't expect the
commandment of purity to go around
wearing nothing except patches of
darkness here and there you might expect
her to dress more modestly however these
are mostly superficial surface level
observations in truth there iary proves
to be a moral person when we get a
glimpse of what happened 3,000 years ago
we see that their iary seems ready to
trust Elizabeth until Ludo shell makes
it look like Elizabeth tricked the
demons derriere he only gets violent
after she witnesses a huge number of
demons including her sister being killed
by the goddesses right before her eyes
but who wouldn't go crazy in that
situation later she doesn't want to take
part in the fighting anymore she just
wants to live a quiet life with Mon
speed in a human village derriere he
even desperately wishes to save the
human souls that s serosa wants to
devour eventually after a serosa kills
won't speed the person most important to
derriere e we find out that s serosa was
actually mild at that point
derriere he actually decides to try and
help mile and save him from the
commandments despite the fact that he
killed the man she loved she decides to
sacrifice her life in order to try and
help him and everyone else by ending the
holy war it doesn't really get any more
moral than that in the end derriere he
definitely lived up to the commandment
of purity unfortunately we never learned
about the curse that comes with her
commandment we never learned how the
curse would affect people who are impure
in derry Ares presence moles feet was
the command
reticence which has also been referred
to as the commandment of silence
reticence is defined as a kind of
reserved wanting to avoid communication
and not wanting to offer any more
information that is necessary with mold
speeds commandment those who expressed
hidden feelings or emotions in his
presence would have their voices blocked
for these reasons moan speed could never
share his true feelings to dairy Arry
who he loved moan speeds commandment is
reflected in the fact that he is often
drawn without a mouth he also keeps his
original power and how it works a secret
as he explains to esta rosa a magician
doesn't reveal his tricks he purposely
kept his power a secret so he could
catch his enemies off guard in the
future it actually almost worked and it
looked like he would have defeated esta
rosa if there iary didn't let her guard
down but alas she did and Mon spiit
sacrificed himself for her right up to
the end Mon speed kept his secret before
he sacrifices himself most Pete
apologizes to derriere II in his mind he
thinks that he won't tell her what he
wanted to say because he will no longer
be able to stay by her side and protect
her so even in the end he didn't want to
offer any information that he didn't
deem necessary and since he wouldn't be
around anymore he didn't think it was
necessary to share his feelings with
derriere II most Pete is one of my
favorite Commandments you can let me
know who your favorite commandment is in
the comments we also know that Esther
OSA could use the commandment of
reticence to make it so that King was
unable to use his magic until he
transformed to his new Oh P king of rock
form zelgius was the commandment of
piety anyone who turns their back on
zelgius while he possesses the
commandment becomes cursed into serving
the demon king and zelgius his
representative piety is defined as a
belief or point of view that is accepted
with unthinking unconventional reverence
Zelda's reverence or deep respect is
directed towards his father the demon
king for a large portion of the series
in Chapter 304 zelgius thinks to himself
that Mele Otis has something he never
had the courage to make an enemy out of
the world for the sake of those he
treasured most even before Mele Otis
fell in love with Elizabeth SEL just
loved gelda however unlike Mele Otis
when the vampire clan became an enemy of
the demon clan
the zelgius did not fight against his
father for the sake of his lover
instead he sealed all of the vampires
away including gelda when his father
ordered him to execute that obviously he
didn't directly follow his father's
orders
but he did take his father's side over
his lovers
later after he took over melioidosis
body the demon king tells Audra's that
his loyalty has always been his one
saving grace nevertheless eventually
zelgius decides to stand against his
father
he eventually realizes that his father
is an unjust god and that loyalty to him
means forsaking gelda his brother and a
world where everyone can live in peace
the things he cares about the most so
although it can be said that he betrayed
the demon king he did so because in the
end he chose to be loyal to the love of
his life instead commodious possessed
the commandment of piety before zelgius
did from the little we see of him he
seems to be blindly loyal to the demon
king he hates the goddesses and everyone
who's taken their side calling them
little goddess lapdogs when Milly oldest
arrives to the battle scene commodious
calls Mele Otis using the honorific sama
after his name which is similar to
saying Lord Mele Otis it shows that he
has great respect for him the son of the
demon king he is also shocked when Mele
Otis seemingly betrays him by taking the
side of a fairy and a giant the fact
emilio de student tried to use words to
get calm adios to switch sides shows
that he felt that calm adios his loyalty
to the demon king was too strong to even
attempt swaying him calm adios from what
we've seen seem to have perfectly
embodied his commandments lastly we'll
talk about the commandment of love Mele
Otis possessed the commandment of love
before Esther OSA aka mile did all who
Harbor hatred in the presence of the
commandment of love will lose their
ability to hurt others the commandment
can stop people from grasping their
swords clenching their fists or even
walking towards the possessor love can
be defined in many ways but one way is a
feeling of strong and constant affection
for a person formerly Otis this person
ended up being Elizabeth another useful
definition of love is an unselfish loyal
and benevolent concern for the good of
another before Elizabeth Mellie Otis was
the commander of the ten commands
he was on track to eventually become the
demon king he was greatly admired by his
younger brother and the other members of
the demon clan yes he gave all that away
so that he could unselfishly help
Elizabeth the woman he loved he went
from being the most respected member of
the demon clan to being a traitor and
its most hated member because of love in
fact the whole series revolves around
Mele Otis's love for Elizabeth he talks
about how he'd have no reason to live
without her and his goal from the
beginning is to fulfill her wish thus
love is definitely the perfect
commandment for meliodas because ever
since he met Elizabeth his love for her
has driven his actions ironically it is
because he falls in love that he
actually ends up losing his commandment
of love to a serosa aka a mile in the
beginning esther osa appears like quite
the villain he kills her main character
Mellie Otis at least temporarily however
even as he's hurting Mellie Otis he
speaks of love he says what he's doing
he's doing because he loves Mellie Otis
even as he kills him he has tears
flowing down his eyes and says goodbye
brother my beloved brother he is being
honest his tears and the fact that he's
not being affected by the commandment of
love are proof that he doesn't hate
Mellie Otis despite the fact that he's
doing something as horrible as killing
him as the series goes on esther also
doesn't act very loving to say the least
not only does he fight against the sins
he also kills his fellow commandant
Smoltz Pete and Derry area as we find
out later though this is a side effect
of the commandments that he absorbed
since he's a goddess the darkness is
negatively impacting his psyche we see
that before he had a commandant a child
mile couldn't even kill a single bug we
also find out that he loved Elizabeth
- just like Mellie Otis did so in that
way it seems fitting that they both
shared the same commandment of love when
he finally gets freed from the power of
the commandments that were destroying
him he's back to his normal more loving
self however even the mile of the path
made mistakes
he killed demons including demon go
Thurs lover because he thought he was
freeing them from their impure cages he
eventually sees the error of his ways
and chooses to help end the holy war
mile despite the shame he feels after
what he's done while he thought he was
us to roast
goes on to risk his life in order to
help those people who were previously
his enemies including Gotha who turned
him into ester osa in the first place he
act selflessly helping those who hurt
him so you can say that he definitely
lived up to the commandment of love
however as with Mellie Otis he had to
lose the commandment of love before he
could fully embody love and that is it
for today's video thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this video
definitely smash that like button to let
me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you get notified when future some
dudley sends videos come out let me know
which commandments story is your
favorite in the comments below and let
me know what seven deadly sins video you
would like to see in the future thanks
again to nord VPN for sponsoring this
video you can find their incredible deal
in the description thank you so much for
watching and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]